ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
ค่ะผู้หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะก็กลับมาพบกับพวกเรา
นะในวิธีคิดหน้า
ไม่ใช่แล้วค่ะ
วีดีโอระดับบีกินเนอร์น้องมีกินแน่นะคะ
กับครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูฟ้านะคะครูฟ้าคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันนี้วันอังคาร
วันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 3
ค่ะ
3  3
สถานที่สาวเหรอฟ้า
8 ค่าแรงคานที่แปดอะเมื่อวันที่ 3 หรอ of
Cool  Fire
อ่ะเดือนอะไรคะคือฟ้าเดือนมีนาคมค่ะค่ะ
อันนี้เดือนที่ 3 ค่ะ
ตีผชอะไรคะมีผช
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะดีพ.ต.ต.
2022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าเมื่อวานนี้
วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่ 7 ค่ะ
เดือนเดือนมีนาคมปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ราคาค่ะสอบพรุ่งวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพุธที่ 9 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนมีนาคมมีผช
2565  a  Call ส 2  0
2255 แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูป๊าตอน
นี้เวลา
11:00 น
11 โมงกี่นาทีคะ
3 นาทีค่ะ
11:03 หนึ่งก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
วันเป็นตอนกลางวันไอยะอ่ะผู้หญิงกินข้าว
หรือยังคะครีมกินข้าวหรือยังใช่ไหม 1 นาง
ไว้ได้กินครูบาสกินข้าวหรือยังคะครูฟ้า
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะโอ้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยอิ่มได้ไหม
แบบประเทศอิ่มแล้ว
น้องกินข้าวแล้วอิ่มแล้วนะนักเรียนผู้
หญิงเนี่ยยังไม่ได้กินก็คิดใช่ไหมคิดเอง
กินอะไรดีนะ
จ๊ะคิดอะไรอ่ะอะไรดีนะก็ต้องเช็คที่
โทรศัพท์นะคะต้องมีโทรศัพท์ครูฟ้ามี
โทรศัพท์ไหมคะฟ้ามีโทรศัพท์ค่ะใช่ไหม
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยก็มีแอพพลิเคชั่นเสื้อมั้ย
เอ้อเคชั่นอาหารใช่ไหมผู้หญิงถ่าย
แอพพลิเคชั่นอาหารที่
อา
ลิเคชั่นส์หาน่ารัก
นั้นเป็นแอปพลิเคชันอาหารอันนี้เป็นอาหาร
สมัย
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวใช่ไหมดู
ดู Application อาหารดูเสร็จยังไม่หิวก็
เลยเล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นโทรศัพท์
ดู YouTube บ้างเล่น Facebook ใช่ไหมเล่น
Facebook บ้าง
เล่นอะไร
เขาเล่นอะไรกันเล่นไลน์สมัยเล่นไลน์บ้าง
ก็เล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นเล่นๆจนถึงตอนนี้ใช่
ไหม 11:00 นยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเลย
กูยังไง
นอนเล่นโทรศัพท์อยู่มาเล่น
2 ชั่วโมงเล่นโทรศัพท์เนี่ย 2 ชั่วโมง
รีปากครูมากรูป
เล่นโทรศัพท์ไหมคะชอบค่ะลูกค้าชอบเล่น
โทรศัพท์โอ้ 1 วันนะ 1 วันทรูฟ้าเนี่ย
เล่นโทรศัพท์กี่ชั่วโมง 1 วันวัน
23 ชั่วโมง
โทรศัพท์ 23 ชั่วโมงแล้ว
1 ชั่วโมงไม่ได้เล่นโทรศัพท์ไม่ได้เล่น
โทรศัพท์นอน
หรือเปล่าวะครูฟ้า
แอบ
เล่นโทรศัพท์ในไม่ชอบเล่นโทรศัพท์มากๆชอบ
เล่นโทรศัพท์ไงโทรศัพท์มันมีแอปพลิเคชั่น
และก็เล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นเกมอยู่ไหมยังไงใน
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยมีเกมและผู้หญิงแน่นะคะอ่า
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยไม่มีเกมเนาะไม่เอาส่วนใหญ่
ก็เล่น Facebook ใช่ไหมหรือว่า
โซเชียลมีเดีย
แต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นเกมเล่นเกมในโทรศัพท์
ตั้งแต่โทรศัพท์
พ่อเล่นเกมในโทรศัพท์ฝาดแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เล่นเกมในคอมพิวเตอร์ไหมคะ
คอมพิวเตอร์เนาะค่ะ
อันนี้คอมพิวเตอร์มั้ยคะ
นะคะโต๊ะคอมพิวเตอร์ใช้ครูฟ้านะเล่นเกมใน
คอมพิวเตอร์ไหมมาเล่นเกมในคอมพิวเตอร์ผู้
หญิงคู่ช้างให้ดูได้ครูฟ้าเล่นเกมอะไรใน
คอมพิวเตอร์
ปาเล่นเกม
ฉอันนี้ลิเกในคอมพิวเตอร์ในคอมพิวเตอร์
ครูฟ้าเหรอคะเกมคอมพิวเตอร์ครูฟ้าค่ะเกม
ใช่ไหมเกมที่กูฟ้าเล่น
Dead  By  Daylight เนี่ยนะคะ ir เกมลูก
ค้าเล่นนี่เกมคอมพิวเตอร์ค่ะคุณเกมครูฟ้า
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าเนี่ย 1 วันใช่ไหมคะ 1 วัน
ครูฟ้าเล่นโทรศัพท์ 23 ชั่วโมง
เล่นเกมกี่ชั่วโมงอ่ะแค่
ไหนและในเกม 3 ชั่วโมง
24 ชั่วโมงได้ไหม
กูฟ้าเล่นเกม 24 ชั่วโมงหนูโอ๋
เยอะไหมหางเยอะมากๆ
ให้หน่อย
ถ้าครูฟ้าเล่นสมัยเล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นเกมมาก
ๆครูฟ้าก็ไม่มีเวลา
เล่นกีฬาสิคะส่วนกีฬาเนี่ยกีฬาให้หาคู่
ป๋าไม่ได้เล่นกีฬาเลยผู้หญิง
ทำยังไงดี
กีฬานี่พวกครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นโทรศัพท์หน่วย
เล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นเกม
เล่นเกม
24 ชั่วโมงก็หายหมดแล้วใช่ไหมคะไม่มี
เวลาเล่นกีฬา
ไทยอ่ะไม่มีเวลาเล่นกีฬาเลยแต่ถ้า
ไม่สบาย
ลา 1 วันอย่างเงี้ยครูฟ้าไม่ไม่เล่นเกม
ไม่เล่นโทรศัพท์
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นกีฬาไหม
เล่นกีฬาค่ะคู่หญิงไฟฟ้าก็เล่นกีฬาใช่ไหม
คะแต่ผมไม่ใช่วินเซิร์ฟเนาะ
ครูฟ้าเล่นกีฬาอะไรคะ
มีอะไรบ้าง
ครูฟ้าเล่นวินเซิร์ฟมั้ยโง่
กูฟาร์มไม่เล่นวินเซิร์ฟนะคะไม่เล่น
วินเซิร์ฟเล่นไม่เป็น
ไม่เข้า
มีเทคนิค
กูฟ้าเล่นปิงปองไหม
จริงเปองได้นิดหน่อยก็คือฟ้าก่อนเล่นเล่น
ครูฟ้าเล่นสนุกเกอร์ไหมคะ
เล่นสนุกเกอร์
ในแอพพลิเคชั่นเป็นเกมได้ไหมนะอะไรกีฬา
กีฬาแบบนี้จะนี่ครูฟ้าแล้วก็มีไม้มีลูก
สนุ๊กแล้วก็คือฟ้ากับเล่นสนุกเกอร์ที่ไม่
ใช่เกมไม่เล่นสนุกเกอร์ค่ะก็ไม่เล่นสมัย
ที่มีเวลานะอ่าเล่นเทนนิสไหมคะ
ไม่เล่นเทนนิสค่ะ
เลื่อนวอลเลย์บอลไหมคะ
เล่นวอลเลย์บอลได้เล่น
เล่นวันอันนี้โซฟาน่าจะเล่นเล่นแบดมินตัน
มันมาเล่นแบบมินตันค่ะชอบ
รุ่นบาสเกตบอลไหมคะเล่นบาสเก็ตบอลค่ะ
นี่เนาะ
เล่นกอล์ฟไหมคะ
ไม่เล่นกอล์ฟค่ะไม่เล่นกอล์ฟมีก็ไม่เล่น
นะโอ้เล่นฟุตบอลไหมคะ
ไม่เล่นฟุตบอลค่ะไม่เล่นฟุตบอล
เล่นโบว์ลิ่งไหมคะอันนี้เป็นเกมด้วยนะ
โบว์ลิ่งเล่นโบว์ลิ่งไว้
ไม่เล่นค่ะไม่เล่นเล่นโบว์ลิ่ง
หรือยังเนี่ยผมฟ้าที่ครูฟ้าจะเล่นได้ออก
มีอันนึงครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยอะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เล่นกีฬาก็คือฟ้าเล่นวอลเลย์บอลเล่นดู
แบดมินตันแล้วก็เล่นบาสเก็ตบอล
ครูฟ้าเล่นโยคะไหม
อยู่คะไปใส่ๆๆเปิดให้นักเรียนดูได้เลย
ครับฟ้า
อันนึงนะอาจารย์อะไรขึ้นคะว่าโยคะคนที่
เค้าเล่นกีฬานะโยคะครูฟ้าเล่นโยคะไหมอุ้ย
ไปพิมพ์ก่อนนะ
ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่เล่นอยู่คะ
ก็เลยถามครูฟ้าอ่ะเล่นโยคะไหม
EP โยคะ
โยคะ
โห
ยกมากอยู่เค้าฟังเล่นอยู่คะไหมไม่
ชื่อเล่นโลคะ
ก็คือเล่นโทรศัพท์
เล่นคอมพิวเตอร์สวยมีคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็
เล่นมีเม้าส์แล้วก็เล่นคอมพิวเตอร์
ก็ว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นโทรศัพท์ใช่
ไหมคะงาเล่นกีฬาเล่นกีฬาหน่อยนะคะหาง
เกมส์เต้นเกมส์
ครูฟ้าเล่นตุ๊กตาไหมมีตุ๊กตาแล้วก็เล่น
ตุ๊กตา
เต้นตุ๊กตา
ต้ม
คุณเท่าฟ้าเล่นตุ๊กตาด้วยเหรอคะ
จริงๆฟ้าได้มีตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้ด้วยนะโห
อยู่ต่อไม่ได้เอาขึ้นมานะตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้กู
ป่าฉะนั้นมีบายพี่มาพี่แบบว่าอย่างเงี้ย
ก็เปิดให้ดูนะ
โป้โยคะค่ะ
หมีใช่ไหมค่ะ
หน้าเป็นตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้แบบนี้อ่ะกูว่ามี
เยอะๆนะมีบาร์บี้มีบาร์บี้มีบางที่แบบนี้
จะในรูปเนี่ยมีบาร์บี้มีตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้
เยอะๆครูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้ด้วย
เล่นตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้ด้วยค่ะตอนนี้ก็เล่น
เหรอคะให้หาบ่อนี้ก็เล่นกูฟังชอบหยิบ
ตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้มาแล้วจงใช้ใส่ค่ะเขา
ก็
จะอ่ะกูฟ้าเนี่ยจะเล่นตุ๊กตานะตุ๊กตา
เนี่ยภูฟ้าเล่นนะคะเล่นกีฬานิดหน่อย
เล่นโทรศัพท์ใส่ไหมคะเล่นน่าจับมากๆ
เล่นเกมส์เล่นเกมส์มากๆแล้วครูฟ้าเล่น
สเก็ตบอร์ดไหม
รถเปิดให้นักเรียนดูได้นะคะสเก็ตบอร์ด
ว่าที่ไทยนะที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเล่น
สเก็ตบอร์ดได้น้าโอเค
นี่หาสเก็ตบอร์ด
โอ้ว
สเก็ตบอร์ดล่ะครูฟ้าเล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดไหมคะ
กูมาเล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดไอ้นิดหน่อยอ่ะใครไป
เล่นจะเล่นนิดหน่อยใช่ไหมคะเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยเอ่อเล่นโทรศัพท์เล่นเกมแหละ 24
ชั่วโมง
อาจจะเล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดประมาณ 3 นาทีนะ
น.ศ.นาทีเล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดตัวประเทศไทยเนี่ย
40 องศาเซลเซียสนะคะนักเรียน
ร้อนนอกเล่นสเก็ตบอร์ดเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ค่ะแล้วก็คือฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นมา
เล่นอะไรอีก
เล่นอันนี้ค่ะผู้หญิงอะไรคะแต่ของเพราะ
ว่ากูมาเอาไปเก็บไว้อีกห้องนึงนะ
เล่นกีตาร์ค่ะโอ้โอ๋
เล่นกีตาร์ได้เล่นกีตาร์ได้ค่ะครูฟ้ามี
กีตาร์
แต่ว่ามี
กีตาร์เท่าไหร่หนึ่งตัวมีกีตาร์ 1 คู
เลเล่ 1  on ครูบาก็เล่นกีต้าร์
ไทยหาเล่นกีต้าร์และก็อูคูเลเล่อาคูเลเล่
ได้ค่ะอ้าวแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ย 1 วันเนาะเล่น
กีตาร์กี่ชั่วโมงคะ 1 วัน
1 วันครูสั้นเล่นกีตาร์ 5 ชั่วโมงค่ะขอ
กูกู
ก็เล่นกีตาร์ 5 ชั่วโมง 1 วันไหนดีนะครู
ฟ้าดีดีมากกว่าเล่นเกมเก็บ
24 ชั่วโมงสงสัยคือฟ้าก็เล่นกีต้าร์เล่น
กีต้าร์ด้วย
ไอค่ะก็กูฟ้าก็เล่นหิมะเล่นกีตาร์คะแต่
ว่า
เป็นนิดหน่อยจริงที่คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิง
นะคะครูฟ้า
3 ผู้หญิงอยู่ Condominium ใช่ไหม
คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงเนี่ยมีที่อยู่ใต้มี
คูเลเล่อยู่ข้างล่าง
ดูเขาอยู่อีกห้องนึงแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่
เล่นนะคะไม่เล่นดู
น้อยผู้หญิงไม่เล่นหญิงไม่ชอบเล่นหรอคะ
หญิงไม่เข้าใจไม่เข้าใจกีต้าร์เล่นยังไง
กูคูเลเล่เล่นยังไงแต่ต้องให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
สอนฉันคุยหญิงเทคนิคอ่า
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยอ่าเล่นกีตาร์ใช่ไหมคะ
เล่นโทรศัพท์เนาะเล่นเกม
เล่นกีฬา
เล่นตุ๊กตา
ฟ้าชอบเล่นอะไรมากที่สุด
ลูกค้าชอบเล่น
เกมค่ะ
ผู้หญิงรู้แล้วครูฟ้าถ้าชอบเล่นเกมมากที่
สุดเลยไหมคะ
เกมคือที่สุดนะค่ะ
[เพลง]
หลายค่ะก็ไม่รู้นักเรียนชอบเล่นอะไรมาก
ที่สุดนะคะมากๆแล้วก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้
นะคะส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะแล้ว
เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดี
ค่ะอ่ะ